project Veritas
which you guys all know project Veritas
and I've I've had uh what's his name
I've had uh James O'Keefe on the show
um they do great work uncovering
basically they get they do they do spy
videos people have accused them of
manipulation a whole bunch but a lot of
the stuff that they do is quite good
they sat down with a guy at a restaurant
named Jordan tishton Walker he is
advisor director and he basically said
that yes they do want to mutate the
virus meaning they do want to mutate
covet and other viruses so that they can
keep people vaccinated this is and then
just watch this whole thing this is wild
Pfizer ultimately is thinking about
mutating covet well that is not what we
say to the public no don't tell anyone
yeah
you know how the virus keeps mutating
yeah well one of the things we're
exploring is like why don't we just
mutate it ourselves so we could talk
about
develop new vaccines right so we have to
do that if we're gonna do that though
there's a risk of like as you could
imagine no one wants to be having a
farmer company mutating to be like very
controlled to make sure that this virus
that you mutate it doesn't create
something like you know it's those
everywhere something crazy is the way
that the virus started and moving on it
to be honest like it's it makes no sense
if this virus popped out of nowhere like
yeah I know me Jordan Tristan Walker a
director of research and development
strategic operations and mRNA scientific
planning advisor it sounds like gain of
function to me
but you do like things like selected
directional mutations to try and see if
you can make more protein yeah so
they're the areas research I'm going
about that I don't know how that's gonna
work we're not being more outbreaks
because like Jesus Christ this is
absolutely wild this guy is a director
advisor fact okay he is doing research
with the MRNA vaccine fact and what he
talks about there is something called
directed evolution
directed Evolution this is gain of
function and that's he's playing these
linguistic games around it gain of
function when you manipulate right what
do they want to do they want to mutate a
virus they want to gain a function of
the virus so you have a virus I mean
this is this is just like basic stuff
you have a virus that's out there then
what were they doing at Wuhan they were
studying how do you manipulate that
virus to gain a function of that virus
so you can do something else whether you
want to weaponize it or anything else
but they play all of these linguistic
aims so when the guy says to him that uh
directed Evolution sounds a lot like
game uh uh gain of function he's like
well not really but then you know he's
laughing through it and he kinds of
admits it and if you want to link this
to our earlier story where we started
today remember when everyone kept saying
for years what you guys do with Twitter
is Shadow Banning and what uh Jack
Dorsey testified was we do not Shadow
band so when the Twitter files came out
you know what they called it visibility
filtering so it's the exact same thing
whether it's directed Evolution gain of
function or visibility filtering and
Shadow Banning it is the same exact
thing so anyway this guy is now being
exposed these are his words right these
are his words he's being exposed by
project Veritas and then James O'Keefe
walks in they have the aha moment and
then all hell breaks loose
hey there is this seat taken you work
for Pfizer my question for you is why is
Pfizer want to hide from the public the
fact that they're mutating the covet
viruses I'm literally a liar I was
trying to impress a person on a date
don't touch me well this is not why the
way don't tell anybody who's just
working in a company to literally help
the public
you really did please read the cops as
soon as possible
can you please unlock your door no no
don't let them leave please unlock the
door
please unlock please unlock the door
please unlock the door
lock the door
unlock the door unlock the door I mean
it's like to catch a predator it's wild
[Music]